foreign
George the Utes what's up Breck oh hey
Dr John how are you I'm good man how are
you
well I'm trying to do better that's why
I'm calling I guess hey me too man me
too so what's up
so
um I have a situation in my marriage
like six months in
I I like fell back into porn and I came
forward to my wife and I explained to
her that you know this has been going on
since my teenage years and it's always
been like
you know a week on and then several
months off and you know it's been even a
couple years in between you know times
that I've fallen into it so I try to
explain it to her I was like I don't
know why you know I'm just this little
rubber band and I keep snapping back and
I kind of cut it and you know set myself
free but
um I've really connected with her and
really tried to be open and honest with
her with where I'm at but
you know with that I know that feelings
of self-image and and lack of trust kind
of start creeping in and so I'm really
struggling with like feelings of
frustration from constantly asking to
trust me and just I just feel like I'm
like spinning my wheels you know
um
so what have you what have you done
different
so
I've never I've never really had a
support person you know it's always been
like I would tell my parents you know
growing up hey I did this and they'd be
like well don't fix it you know so
listen listen if I'm her
there's a value
in my home that me and my brand new
husband agreed on and then my husband
came to me and said hey I violated this
value I'm coming forward I'm being
honest about it which is Noble good for
you
and then it's followed up with yeah this
has just been a thing I've been dealing
with since I was little since I was real
young and it just keeps coming back and
um I don't want it to be there but it
just keeps coming back so
all right uh don't judge me and don't
hold me accountable to it and don't get
mad at me let's go get uh some pancakes
that is very different than enough is
enough is enough
I'm gonna go join an essay group
I'm gonna go join a uh
any number of groups that meet all over
the United States
um a Celebrate Recovery Group but in any
number of things
I'm gonna go see a counselor I'm gonna
go get very serious about this
and you haven't done that which tells me
I mean you like the idea of not having
these week-long shame spirals but you
also
like the idea of having like a week-long
binge Fair
okay
I don't know I'm I'm absolutely
terrified of falling back
I know but not terrified enough to do
something
you're just sitting there being
terrified
which in a crazy twist of fate
the more wound up you are the more white
knuckling you do the more you slowly
grind off your ability to make good
decisions
and you burn the edges off and you burn
the edges off and you know what makes
everything feel better
connected relationships and you don't
have that you know a cheap substitute
for a connected relationship pornography
and so you by not being willing to go
meet with some people and say hey this
is me and I've struggled with this for a
long time
um
how are you guys doing my name is Breck
I'm struggling
how are you this week Breck good I had a
good week how are you this week Brett I
I fell off man I didn't do so well or I
haven't looked at pornography but I've
been I ate four large pizzas this week
and I'm struggling with my diet like
whatever the thing is if you don't have
that your body's gonna go get it it's
going to get it in the quickest easiest
way possible
so you can say you're terrified to not
to to fall back into this thing but
you're not terrified enough to do
something
so if I'm your wife I'm just watching a
lot of lip service and then you tell me
you've been lip servicing this for a
long long time
and nothing's changed and so she's
looking at her future like well I guess
it's just going to be my marriage
and so I actually think she's right to
keep asking you or to not trust you
because you're not giving her any
alternative actions
well I mean at first when at first when
I told her you know she was very sweet
about it and and you know we we sat down
I I went to a counselor and I just kind
of tried to identify like triggers and
we set up a plan and I keep a little
note in my wallet and we have an
agreement that it was it was after a big
argument and that I just felt inadequate
that I just wanted to almost hurt myself
with it
and and so that you know our form of
dealing with that is no matter what like
if we have an argument she can just say
hey leave your phone and I'll go out of
the room and
and just kind of decompress and and sit
there and
think about and kind of cool down but
I didn't get that she'll say leave your
phone and you just leave your phone yeah
yeah at any time she just says hey leave
your phone here and so she'll I'll give
it to her and then I'll just go off and
be in her room alone and try and cool
down you know because it's it's always
been like from an argument or from like
a depressive episode that I
okay I see what you're saying so you
have a trigger and
the trigger as you're describing it is a
it's a
fracture in a relationship
your body feels unsafe
and a way that soothes that discomfort
is pornography right
I think so yeah and dude you're not
weird
you don't mean you're not like there's
millions and millions and millions and
millions of of men and women in your
exact situation in fact what makes you
kind of weird is that you don't want to
that to be your default setting anymore
and so what I would challenge you on is
identifying the trig all you're looking
for is space here
between stimulus and response
okay
yeah
you cannot just withdraw an activity
withdraw A coping mechanism and not
establish something else in its place
addiction doesn't work like that
so you can't just pace around the house
in a minute until the urge passes
foreign
you're gonna have to
go for a jog you're gonna have to call a
friend you're gonna have to call a
sponsor and get the relational
connectivity there
that makes sense yeah I just I I don't
know I feel like I've made it made
changes but what you're saying is like
that feels like it's the final kicker
and so I don't know I just have been
feeling like
almost an imposter because I'm saying
hey you know this is what happens I've
made changes and I feel like this is
where I'm at now but I don't want to
like minimize what I did or minimize it
you know the breaking values there I
just there's no sense in going backwards
dude yeah that's you beating yourself up
and at some point
probably not just yet but at some point
your wife's gonna have to decide to stop
hedging her bets by calling this back in
calling this back in calling this back
in
because she's going to try to keep
herself safe
by keeping some moral High ground and
I'm sure she's not perfect either
and she's gonna have some this is gonna
be a way she can like a stepping stool
if you will in a raging River and it
will make her feel like she's above The
Fray a little bit it's gonna keep her
safe and she's gonna have to choose to
be vulnerable again if this marriage is
going to work also
both of you are
yeah but how do I how do I ask for that
you can't that's for her
yeah
she's gonna have to choose to open
herself up to get hurt again
just like you are
but I think you have not got radical
enough
you're an alcoholic who has just kept a
few bottles of whiskey just in case
relatives come over
cut the internet off dude
get rid of your phone
get a flip phone that you can't text on
and you're going to lose friends get rid
of all social media
put blocks on get rid of it pour the
whiskey down the sink
this is what I'm talking about
yeah
and you haven't been willing to do that
which means she has to try to stay safe
and so I'm actually on her side right
now
yeah and I'm like I'm on her side too
because I sometimes I just feel like
like crap but well do something do
something
you feel like crap because you're just
you're in a you're in a you're in a
cognitive Loop man you're just in in
you're on a mental treadmill you're just
like a a a mental like mouse and a wheel
just running and you're trying to solve
it by thinking about it stop thinking go
do
go to academy this afternoon or to
Walmart or something and get a couple of
dumbbells and put them in your garage
and when you have an urge put your phone
turn it off
and then go downstairs and do 15 minutes
or 10 minutes or something
or go buy a pair of running shoes and go
for a jogged into your block
you've got to put some things some new
behaviors that are going to be positive
go to a group get somebody you can call
take action do you hear me man
yeah take action take action take action
take action you know what to do yeah I
know I feel like that's the biggest need
in my life is I'm just kind of waiting
and I and I see that it's kind of bled
into other areas of my life I know it
has I know it has
and you think that your marriage
challenges you think your wife is
um not super into you right now because
the pornography it's not
it's because she's finding out that she
might be married to like a wet piece of
toast
right
yeah and here's what pornography gives
you can I be honest with you it makes
you feel a little bit more alive
Fair
yeah that's fair create that aliveness
in your whole life brother
you only get one shot at this thing
yeah
right
what makes you alive
go go just start rattling off top of
your head what makes you alive just
being outside okay what else you know
what else you're one of the most
beautiful parts of the United States
it's for being outside what else I like
exercising I've been getting into biking
I just what else we're new to the area
so I just don't have any friends I need
friends okay get there you go get them
get them
right yeah yeah there's some weird St
George biker Club out there mountain
biker Club I know there is I know there
is
probably a hundred of them
and you're gonna show up to one and
they're gonna be too good you're gonna
show up to another one and it's gonna be
a bunch of like old women and you're
gonna be like probably not probably not
for me you're gonna find them and
they're gonna be there
and there's I guarantee you they'll
Celebrate Recovery groups in your area
guarantee
yeah go go go
you get one shot at this life man
Fair yeah absolutely no you're like me
okay absolutely no go are you in yes
are you sure yes yes okay enough enough
of the well I'm just here and I just
don't want to do this anymore don't
don't make it different make it
different
make it different today you're gonna get
a note card out and you're gonna write
down for the next five days nope the
next seven days you're gonna write down
your daily routine when I wake up what
I'm gonna have for breakfast the
supplements I'm gonna take the exercise
I'm gonna get going to work the
connection I'm gonna have with my wife
the things I'm going to do I'm gonna
make dinner I'm here's the things I'm
gonna do and no matter what no matter
what come hell or high water you're
gonna check off everything on that list
and you're probably gonna add four or
five things to every list too put them
on there anyway and check them off
we are practicing a different way of
doing life
and in every one of those days every day
you're gonna do at least one thing where
you're gonna reach out and connect with
somebody else
whether that's at work it's a group of
strangers it's just going to the to the
bike rider Park I don't know what y'all
bike riders do I'm not that talented
I'll fall off and eat it I break a bone
or two
but get out and get connected
go go go my brother you're worth it and
everybody listening stop thinking about
everything so much go do
go do change your life go